i think a lot of the things that you
know like these bitcoin and trading
you know listen there's windows of
opportunity for everything
i what scares me always scares me about
bitcoin
is that you know i as much as i know
about the government
and how they detest money laundering i
just i just scratch my head and say
how would they allow this to become
something that could so easily be used
to launder money
so what what right now are you seeing
sort of business-wise with all
with all the chaos and with the dinner
that you had with your friend last night
and everyone's sort of hot on bitcoin
right now
and there's there's suddenly a whole
bunch of you know social media
alternatives i think you know a little
bit about what i'm doing with locals.com
there's like a whole bunch of stuff sort
of appearing
are there things that are really
interesting you right now yeah so you
know i have my own
you know my own business which is doing
really well i'm growing it right now
which is a you know
a recruiting business that i'm rolling
out all you know around the world right
now where i
help companies scale by finding them
sales people so
that's my long-term you know
outcome that i see i i think a lot of
the things that you know
like these bitcoin and trading you know
listen there's windows of opportunity
for everything
i what scares me always scares me about
bitcoin
is that you know i as much as i know
about the government
and how they detest money laundering i
just i just scratch my head and say
how would they allow this to become
something that could
so easily be used to launder money and
it can
i don't care i listen i have a lot of
friends that are really successful
that love bitcoin and i have some that
hate bitcoin and the ones that love
bitcoin they're legitimate people
and they're not scamming they're just
like they like it they have their
reasons why
um but it just it's i know enough about
it's very easy to use bitcoin to like
hide money and
you know and do deals that are that
could that would otherwise be much more
difficult to do
uh through the traditional banking
system so my point is like i i just
question i'm not saying that's what
bitcoin is only used for because it's
not
but why would the government's my fear
it's like the government said you know
we spent
all this time trying to stamp out
switzerland and the caymans so what
all right well great let's just get turn
control over now
to a system that we can't control i it
doesn't make sense to me the only thing
that does make sense to me is if it's
the government itself that released
bitcoin
and they know everything like it was
actually the cia or the government
that's behind the whole thing
and like yeah go hide your money that's
great and then like they know where
everything is
that if that came out i'd say aha now it
all
makes sense you know now you're now
you're really going down the rabbit hole
other than that
but other than that other than that i
look i think the technology itself of
blockchain
is really elegant i think it's got a lot
of uses and i think that
i understand that bitcoin is a lot of
people that like it
that and the more people there's a
network effect on that in terms of not
so much for
spending it but the network effect of
the more people that think it's worth
something i guess it really is in some
respect and then
also that we always look at things from
a purview of the united states and it's
having a stable
currency so you know imagine if you're
in a
country or let's say you're in uh peru
or somewhere or chile or
uh in that country and the the currency
is devaluing or
cuba and it's almost impossible to have
us
uh to be able to hold currency because
that's not worth it they would usually
use
dollars but bitcoin is a good old i
guess there's an alternative it's not
very good for transactions
it's a storehouse of values it's much
better than their own
their own basically worthless currency
so i think there's applications for
other countries that we
probably don't realize as much coming
from the united states i've seen it as
they go around the world that
that people in other countries they're
much more thick it's like oh yeah it's
you know
better than my own currency i'll take
that any day so we'll see the jury's out
i i
i'm still ambivalent i think that there
it could go either way right now if the
u.s government doesn't step in
and try to squash it i think it could go
much higher
do you think despite the opportunity
that we have right now because of
because of the chaos um that just sort
of generally the biden administration
with taxes and regulation and all that
stuff is
is going to scare a lot of people from
from building the right businesses
what i think is that typically a
president
inherits what they got from the
administration before them
so biden will reap the rewards of
trumpism and that will probably last for
the first year or so
maybe two and then the effects of
bidenism whatever that might be
and the liberal policies will start to
really take hold
more in the second and third year and
even fourth year of his term so i think
this is really weird
thing like you know administrations you
know you know they either get the credit
or blame for things that really probably
weren't
much of their own doing um and my
biggest
thing is immigration i i don't get it i
just don't understand i don't understand
uh i there's no doubt the immigration
system is broken i have clients who are
immigration lawyers and so i really have
a very good insight into immigration
right now
really good insight so i understand the
system is terrible it's broken it needs
to change
there's a lot of terrible things
happening to illegal aliens that
shouldn't be happening
that you probably i couldn't believe it
until i actually saw it myself that
there are things that it wasn't like
trump's fault it's been happening for a
long time you know it has started until
obama
got worse under trump um but to let's
say
everyone can stay it's insane it's it's
it's like
it's pissing in the eye of every person
that legally came here as much as
forgiving student loans is pissing in
the eye of every person
who went to school borrow money and paid
it back it's like there's like this
moral hazard here in this thing and so
you know obviously the the intelligent
person would say
if i'm gonna make no consequence for
sneaking in everyone's gonna come and
sneak in
if i make no consequence for not paying
back student loans no one's gonna pay
back their loans
so there's a huge issue with these
things and i think that's i think that
the common theme that you and i think
agree on is that like about just
personal responsibility
for one's actions and i think that's
like almost the underlying theme on
on the left is like there's almost a
lack of personal responsibility for
one's
actions and where one is in life at this
moment
where where does just common sense fall
into that because it's interesting when
i listen to you it's like i
i know you can go deep on all all the
business stuff and
and how to help people succeed and all
that but you just strike me actually
more as just like a common sense guy
more than anything in a way that may be
a long island thing too at some level or
like a queen's thing
i think that i think that con
i think common sense is much more
easily shown when one isn't saddled with
prejudices
like i like i don't care about any of
the social stuff on either side
i just don't like to me i think people
should just
do and be what they want and have like i
i think a lot of the problems with the
with these both parties is they
represent
things that are so like they're not like
there's politics and there's other
things
you know i'm trying to say it like like
for me i think i see things really
clearly because like
i don't like i don't care like i always
say i'm prejudiced against two types of
people
lazy people and stupid people other than
that i love or hate everybody else
equally right like
i think a lot i think there still is out
there there's a lot of prejudice people
have a lot of like um just a lot of
like they come into the into the into an
idea like not
looking at it from a level playing field
and i think what i'm what i think one
thing i do pretty well
is i'm able to look at i'm able to take
a step back and go like it's called
going better on my own
i just take a step back okay and all in
truth all things being equal like let's
take the [ __ ] out of this thing
what's the real truth to you like i
think i have a pretty decent
read i guess everyone probably thinks
that
right no i really think i have a pretty
good read
you know i'm i'm well educated i i i
make sure i listen to a lot of different
points of view
so i think that if i sound reasonable of
course i'm not
allowing a belief i have about some a
core belief i have
whether it's about abortion or or
or being gay or this it's like to me
it's so stupid
like to allow that to color your your
your judgment
for other decisions but it does i think
it does all the time and it's really
destructive to uh to the country and to
the world
i really think it is if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell